around the prince a ring of Steel
this is the alemão favela in the north
of Rio de Janeiro
a little more than a year ago security
forces stormed a zone in search of gangs
and the drugs they peddle it's still not
safe
every precautions taken as Prince
Harry's makes his way through its narrow
streets but all the Prince encountered
in a place where crime violence and
poverty is the norm the unannounced
arrival of the Prince appeared a welcome
distraction but on a personal level the
princes keen to reflect the work his
charities do for the underprivileged and
here in alemão unfulfilled potential is
which is where this new Community Center
funded by Sport Relief comes in
ten-year-old riser is helping her family
to improve their reading she is fiercely
bright with big plans she's not the only
one in Alamo
who needs a helping hand
harry's shown he can handle duties on
behalf of the queen and the government
but what matters most to the prince is
helping those who most need support Paul
Harrison Sky News Rio de Janeiro